out some strategies subtracting decimals
that involve hundredths so for example
if i have
0.69 or
69 hundredths and from that i want to
subtract
0.34 or 34 hundredths what is that going
to be pause this video and see if you
can compute this
so there's a bunch of ways to think
about it one way to think about it is
this is 69 hundredths
hundredths
and from that we are subtracting 34
and so this boils down to i have 69 of
something in this case hundredths
in this case hundreds i'm going to take
away 34 of them so what am i left with
well what's 69 minus 34
well 9 ones minus 30 or i should say 9
minus 4 is going to be 5
and 60 minus 30 is going to be 30.
so i'm left with 35 hundredths
hundredths
which i can write as 0.35
now another way i could think about it
is i could break up the tenths the and
then the left over hundredths so i could
view this as
six tenths let me circle that a little
bit better
six tenths minus three tenths
so six tenths
minus three
minus three tenths
plus
plus nine hundredths
minus four hundredths
so plus
nine
hundredths
minus
four
hundredths
and we're going to get the same answer
so i have six tenths and i take away
three of them that's going to give me
three tenths or i could just write that
as 0.3
and then to that i would have to add
nine
nine hundredths
minus four hundredths is five hundredths
so zero point zero five so three tenths
and five hundredths is going to be
thirty-five hundredths or we could just
write it this way we could write it as
three tenths we have a three in the
tenths place and five hundredths let me
do that blue color
and
five hundredths or we could do that as
35 hundredths however way these are
different ways of thinking about
subtracting these hundredths
let's do
another example
so let's say
we want to compute
so we would like to compute this
actually will probably be a little bit
more straightforward
three
and forty three hundredths
minus
two what is this going to be equal to
pause the video and see if you can
figure it out
well it might jump out at you that this
is the same thing as 3 plus
43 hundredths
minus 2.
and so you can just look at the ones you
can look at the holes we have three
holes and we're going to take away two
of them so we're going to be left with
one whole and we still have this 43
hundredths so we still have this 43
hundredths so it's gonna be one and
forty three hundredths or we could write
that as one
point
one
point four three so that one maybe was a
little bit more straightforward
but now let's kind of combine the ideas
of these last two examples into one that
might seem a little bit more daunting
so let's say that we
want to subtract we want to figure out
what 65 65.79
minus
42.58 is pause the video and see if you
can figure this out
so multiple ways to do this you could
separate the whole numbers so you could
say this is 65 minus 42
minus 42
plus
and then think about the
and then think about the hundreds
plus 79 hundredths
so
79 hundredths
minus 58 hundredths
minus 58 hundredths and i just i'll
rewrite this in words just to reinforce
this 79 or something 79 hundredths you
could say it's seven tenths and nine
hundredths but it's the same thing as
hundredths
hundredths this is 58
and so 65 minus 42
5 minus 2 on the ones we're going to get
3 and then 60 minus 40 is equal to 20.
so we have 23
plus
23 plus
now 79 hundredths minus 58 hundredths
70 minus 50 is 20
and nine minus eight is one so it's
going to be 21
hundredths
which we can write as
0.21 21 hundredths and so
when we compute this it'll be 23
and
and 21 hundredths this is just one way
to tackle it there are multiple ways
that you could try to tackle a
subtraction problem like this